hi there steve kaufman here again at
lang fest in montreal and i have with me
lydia machova
a friend from bratislava
where she organized with a group of
volunteers of course the bratislava
polyglot gathering and lydia is not only
a polyglot
and a learner of languages but she is
also involved in helping people learn
and i have a number of things i want to
ask you about but i want to start with
that and and of course you're presenting
on that subject here and so what exactly
is this idea of
helping people learn yeah
well it's my it's my own approach to
teaching languages i call it language
mentoring uh because i don't want to
come i don't want people to come to me
and expect to be taught a language that
i know i have the knowledge of and i
just impart the knowledge upon them i
don't think that works uh what i want
them to do is to find their own way how
they can learn a language how they can
spend enough time with the language not
just come to the lessons twice a week
for one hour and a half and to really
learn by themselves and i'll be i'll be
happy to help them with that i'm happy
to show them the resources and the
methods how to work with that but they
need to really do the work okay now
spend enough time on their own i
remember i was at a conference in
germany where
uh
and they said the average corporate
language learner in germany they did a
survey has one hour a week with a
teacher and the average learner puts in
one more hour
that's not very much that's not enough
what has been your experience with the
people that you help yeah uh my
experience that people usually think
they don't have enough time so they go
for the courses with the teacher because
they think oh i don't have enough i
don't have more time anyway but then i
show them ways how they can have fun
with the language and it's not really
seen as learning it's like well you're
reading a book that you love that you
loved in uh reading in another language
so you're just spending time with the
language and suddenly it's not seen as
oh i have to do this this is homework
but oh where can i when can i continue
to read my favorite book but let's
assume read favorite book okay
it's difficult to read a book in another
language yes well there's a few methods
how you can approach that first of all
what you can do is you either get a
bilingual book where you have it one
page and another page right or you get
two copies of the same book which is
something i like to do so i would get
the spanish harry potter and the slovak
harry potter and i would read and if i
cannot find if i don't understand
something and i mean not just one word
some part where i have no clue what
they're talking about i would look up
the slovak part right
uh or you can um
yeah you can go through the the text and
look at words that you don't know for
example through link right so that's
another way how you can work with text
but the thing is you really need to go
through a lot of material it's not
enough if you just read text in a
textbook at a language school right this
i think this will never be enough right
so and and then you help people uh
show them where there are resources show
them how to go about becoming
independent learners and are you able to
convert these people into independent
learners yes and i'm very very happy
about it yeah the first time i did this
uh this experiment because i didn't know
if it would work for other people too i
know it works for me
but i did an experiment with a hundred
students at a university uh they were
language students but they did not
really learn a lot by themselves i mean
the usual approach of a student who
studies to be a translator or
interpreter is oh i go to study to this
university and the university gives me
the language kind of right and i told
them guys let's not do it let's let's
spend a lot of free time with the
language let's watch series let's read
books let's uh you know listen to
podcasts as much as possible we
monitored it in some way and motivated
each other and suddenly they improved
immensely within two months so that's
where i tested it right and now i do it
for people who have nothing to do with
languages like they're not studying it
they don't necessarily like the foreign
languages they don't have a passion for
it but they they develop the passion
right this is so important and so we can
develop
people
the
passions
who tell me they hated english they
hated it for 20 years and they could not
progress suddenly fall in love with one
method one way of working with uh with
the language suddenly they can't stop
right and they spend
people who are working have families a
full-time job whatever spend uh 10 to 15
hours a week with the language and i
have this experience with hundreds of
people now in slovakia so it's
impossible and if you spend that much
time with the language you are going to
improve yes yes and they some might
improve faster than others but they will
all improve and i what i really liked in
your book by the way was you said you
are the best judge of how much you've
improved you don't need a test you don't
have someone to tell you and i honestly
think it's really impossible to tell if
you're now on a b2 or a b1 based on one
test which takes you half an hour right
like it's a just a choice of selection
of the vocabulary right so we agree that
you are the best judge yes because all
of a sudden you understand something
that you didn't understand three months
earlier which is a wonderful feeling it
is and you don't need to take a test
which you might pass and might fail
based on some arbitrary uh you know uh
criteria and you are primarily like me
an input based learner yes and the
question that always comes up within
that we input base learners are asked uh
two two questions really one how do you
then activate it
okay you've got all this input that's
gone in how do you get it to start
coming out and then the second question
is because it's easy to do let's say two
three months of input with language a
put language a aside and start in the
language b
and now there's a possibility of
interference between these two languages
especially if they're related languages
and i think you recently had some
experience with that so
two questions a how do you activate and
b how do you deal with interference yes
well i personally like to start speaking
in a language about two or three months
after i started with the input but this
is for languages that are close to the
languages that i already know i've never
started learning an asian language or
something very uh very far from my
languages so i think i would need more
time in that case but i'm not in a hurry
i don't need to start speaking right
away right i start speaking when i have
some vocabulary and it's not yet a
moment where i would be comfortable
speaking because it takes time but i
think well what people that are learning
their
ex language
have as an advantage is you know it's
going to take time and you're going to
improve we have patience absolutely and
we know we're going to get there you can
even in a way in a weird way you can
enjoy this frustration you know i have
to interrupt just to stress that
even at the beginning when we're
struggling
we know we're going to get there because
we've been in that struggling mode
forget everything no traction getting
nowhere and and it all sounds the same
and we know we're going to get there so
that's a big advantage that we have over
the inexperienced learner and then later
on we know it's a long road to get to
that comfortable fluency level and we're
quite happy to stay there and we're
enjoying it you're not expecting very
rapid improvement within one week and
you're not frustrated oh my god i still
can't speak exactly all right
and and we also know that it will
activate i mean that has been your
experience absolutely
and the best way actually what i do what
i like to do is so i i have some
speaking practice but it may be just two
lessons a week not like very very
intense and then i like to go to the
country and in two weeks i feel like i
could dream i could do anything in there
it's such a freedom i know and that was
my feeling unfortunately i only had like
six days in prague so it wasn't as great
as it could have been i had three weeks
in la vie for ukrainian and one week is
not enough it's two to three weeks
to activate and boom
okay second question you know and i i
mentioned that i had put a lot of effort
into slovak leading up to the uh
conference in bratislava and even though
i had spent so much more time on
ukrainian i met a ukrainian or there
were several ukrainians in batista i
couldn't say a thing yes and yet
i would say half an hour into a
conversation with with solomia in la
life my ukrainian was back that quickly
i have the same experience okay so talk
a little bit about this interference
thing and is it a problem is it
something we should worry about yeah or
or we just accept the fact sometimes we
just can't perform you know that's the
answer i mean i used to worry about that
i was i was hesitating but i want to
start with russian because my polish is
pretty pretty good and pretty uh pretty
advanced i didn't want to lose it
because i've put so much time into it
right so what i did now i did learn
russian because i wanted to travel in
both soviet countries and exactly this
is my experience what happened i was in
russia i took the trans-siberian express
from moscow to mongolia speaking just
russian now i met three polish guys in
uh at the end of my trip i couldn't say
a word and
for the at the beginning i was a bit
scared it's like oh my god i've lost my
polish this is terrible you know like i
i sacrificed it to russian but then i
put russian aside and i concentrated
just on polish and it took me about a
day to gain my full fluency again but
what i what i found out i cannot do is
when i was on the phone with a polish
guy with russians sitting next to me and
they would they would go silent when
they heard me speaking in islamic
language which was not russian and and
they would uh try to translate what i
was saying in polish into russian and i
was on the phone and i couldn't say
anything in any language i was totally
lost for words because these two
languages were coming in at the same
time the same content
you know and simultaneously i couldn't
do it even though i'm a trained
interpreter you know you know and and
we'll sort of close on that on that note
it's of course the brain the brain
learns the brain cannot help but learn
yes exposed to experiences the brain is
going to develop some kind of neural uh
connections uh but sometimes we can't
control it and i find that at times i'll
be speaking
i don't know russian or or when i'm
struggling let's say not russian maybe
it's ukrainian maybe it's slovak and out
comes japanese
yes wow like the i don't know what
happened up there but they kind of took
the wrong turn and when did these things
happen yes we can't control the brain i
think we just need to be confident the
brain will learn
uh it's not perfect
occasionally it will let us down yes but
by and large it does a good job exactly
okay well thank you
all right thank you very much
[Music]
you